controversy over raves back in the news
fifteen-year-old girl who died after a
rave at the LA Coliseum prophet
legislation to protect people at large
events on state property young people
texting each other or emailing and
showing up at the clandestine site doing
a lot of ecstasy I think politics was
very interested in and the media was
very interested in it because you could
attach it's kind of a scene or a group
or population of people that you could
you know either demonizing criticize the
electric daisy carnival or EDC is a
giant festival of electronic music
dancing and lights in the City of Angels
something special was born hundreds of
thousands of people have attended EDC in
Los Angeles for the past thirteen years
but in 2010 a fifteen-year-old girl died
at the event an autopsy later showed
ecstasy in her system the tragedy led
the Los Angeles City Council to ban
Electric Daisy Carnival from the city
and also prompted state Assemblymember
fiona MA to craft a be 74 or Sascha's
law she no 14 year old had many
different types of drugs in her system
so it was very very alarming that young
people of that age were going to these
events mas first impulse was to ban
raves altogether but that approach ran
into some problems we found out later on
that constitutionally you cannot ban a
type of music plus I like my opponents
said you know I didn't really know what
was going on ma decided to better
acquaint herself with raves by attending
one in her district and found contrary
to much of the hype it was not an
altogether terrifying and unpleasant
experience not my style of music but I
can see how people have fun there I went
to a rave in March and was very
surprised seeing 10,000 people in one
location dancing to the same music at
the same time the same beat it was
pretty pretty Iowa music
she is still pushing a B 74 but it's
been modified to simply regulate large
events held on State Fairgrounds
rather than targeting raves in
particular but Li Lu who worked for a
rave safety organization called dance
safe and also was producing a
documentary about the Electric Daisy
Carnival says that politicians in
California and across the nation are
still unfairly targeting ravers when you
kind of do a story about an
out-of-control rock concert
it's almost ioad news still a lot of
people but when you throw in some
colorful kids and you know that rave you
know that's like kind of fresh so I
think that's why people pay attention to
it more much of the political backlash
against raves began in 2002 when
then-senator Joe Biden proposed the
reducing Americans vulnerability to
ecstasy act or the rave Act which he
attached to a popular bill targeting
child abduction whatever public
officials or legislators they try to
push forward a bill or an issue it's
going to be an easier sell if you attach
it to something having to do with
children because it sparks the
protective nature of parents Liu says
the legislation targeting raves is not
the best way to stop kids from
overdosing on ecstasy in fact it drives
the behavior underground some events
even discourage groups like dance safe
from participating in order to avoid the
toxic rave label it's just created this
atmosphere of fear to have any kind of
discussion on drugs it's just kind of
encourage a setting of denial that you
know an event is a rave or an event has
any sort of drug use so there's like
there's a look at separation between the
people go to these events who mostly are
using drugs and then people putting them
on just kind of pretending the drug use
aspect of their it doesn't exist and I
think that's what that's what's led to
tragedies such as Sasha Rodriguez's of
course that will always happen
there's always loopholes as I mentioned
there's a lot of money involved in these
type of events but I believe with the
new secretary the new people appointed
to these boards more sophistication in
terms of what raves are the safer they
will be mom may be approaching the rape
issue with the lighter touch now but her
push for regulation has still targeted
specific aspects of rape culture such as
the use of led
gloves and pacifiers which she says
promotes drug use can't wear gloves with
lights you can't walk around with
stuffed animals I mean all the things
that the wave culture the the promoters
have tried to break down and make it
more like a concert where people go to a
venue to enjoy themselves and not have
all of things that are associated
traditionally in the past with waves no
pacifiers
for example nobody was allowed to to
have pacifiers in the mouth when you
talk about politicians who kind of write
laws or you know around events or
cultures of young people so there's
always going to be a disconnect you know
with Fiona Maas bill especially now
there's been such a huge reaction from
the from young people from the brave
community to say well this doesn't
really make sense
although Maas working to regulate rapes
in her district the city of Los Angeles
outright banned the Electric Daisy
Carnival
but the rave culture is still strong and
vibrant and it's found a more welcomed
home elsewhere Las Vegas
[Music]
Vegas knows how to keep madness and
chaos organized begin with sitting there
doing a very good job what do you think
is the biggest misconception Outsiders
have about ravers yoyo we're conducting
an interview